president Trump posts an unprecedented
an extraordinary roundtable on school
violence and the shootings many of
people there in attendance had either
been at a school shooting or they lost
their loved ones in the school shooting
one of the great powers of the
presidency is the power to convene and
this is something we have not seen
before especially on this issue where
you had such raw emotion outpourings of
grief the president listening super
intently to all of them asking about
ideas it was a very emotional and moving
day but it also gave you some hope that
there could be some achievement going
forward the president said he's going to
have them back and that they would be
coming back and in a much better light
meaning that hopefully that their grief
and hopefully subside because the
government the president says is going
to act well they're gonna take it around
the table here and Jesse Watters I'll
start with you for your thoughts
Americas reached a tipping point on
school violence some of us were tearing
up watching the exchanges it was a
really raw and organic and powerful
moment the president we know takes in
information verbally that's how he takes
his briefings you know he was very
impacted when he saw the pictures of the
Syrian children gassed and this was I
think a moment for him to really take it
all in and listen he talks about being a
protector protecting the border
protecting jobs and it's now up to him
to do whatever he can to protect the
schools and a lot of politicians are all
talk and no action and he's not one of
them I believe but he wants to take
action that's going to have an impact
not just empty action that's not going
to solve any problems he talked about
making America great again but when I
interviewed him he talked about making
America safe again and one of the things
that needs to be addressed is school
safety at the best moment I BLET I
believe Andrew [ __ ] who stood up I
believe he lost his daughter meadow said
forget about the gun issue right now
let's focus first on making schools safe
and there are some great exchanges of
ideas arming teachers at schools mental
institutions enhanced background checks
I mean this kid's been suspended how
many
and no one really intervened my father
ran a school out in Long Island then
after Sandy Hook
they built fences around the school
because you can't have people just
wandering into a school a lot of the
teachers and administrators from some of
the urban areas they have metal
detectors and checkpoints which are
extremely effective so that's something
to look at too and another great moment
iPhones when a guy I believe from Sandy
Hook one of the fathers said we stopped
relying on Washington to fix everything
and we did it ourselves and we really
trained teachers to intervene when they
saw a student with problems and then
take action aggressively the best moment
I think though - at the end the guy just
said listen we've lost our connections
as humans as Americans we don't
recognize people anymore we don't see
things we miss signs and that's the
bottom line when you see something say
something
Americans we're all you know one nation
and you just have to care for one
another and I think this is a really a
starting point for some strong action
the president talked about Greg some
concrete things that obviously he's
thinking about one it was the age at
which you can buy a gun that is set
federally he talked about background
checks concealed carry he's mentioned it
several times and that would be people
in a school that would have a gun that
you but you wouldn't know who that might
be
yeah I mean the interesting thing for me
not just the suggestions but the the
tone in tenor of this conversation is
incredibly important because you know we
make jokes about the president viewing
his administration as a talk show well
so what that was one hell of a talk show
because you've got a bunch of different
opinions and a bunch of people sitting
there who know the topic and know the
topic intimately and expressed
suggestions practical solutions about a
horrible problem and my advice always
stands the biggest obstacle in this
debate is trust the loudest voices do
not trust each other those are not the
loudest voices those were the voices
that you had to listen to and what you
found there were people who disagreed
but they disagreed civilly and you know
I was this mootai I thought that that
this is probably one of the most value
things I've seen in this administration
I also to Jesse's point the thing that
got to me was the Darryl Scott talked
his daughter died and Columbine you know
he's just recently Darryl Scott this
point was was about connection and what
we saw there was connection were too
busy to in this world of division right
now and and and what group do you belong
to in the tribal the tribalism that
infects everything from politics to
identity and what he was trying to say
is you know we need to connect we
connect in broadband that's not the real
thing we have community and the thing is
community means interaction between
police and the people they police it's a
community it's it's at it's at sporting
events it's schools people need to know
who's in their community and need to be
confident enough and I think that there
were there was you know a binder full of
practical solutions there that can be
acted upon and they were pretty and they
were presented in a way that was
non-threatening to either side and
that's what communication and connection
is about didn't mean to interrupt you
but we do have the soundbite from God in
case you didn't hear it earlier let's
listen I just want to share one simple
principle with you that we've learned
over the years as we've worked with
millions and millions of young people
and it comes from something you said
last week in your speech and it was that
we must create a culture of
connectedness we must create a culture
in which our classmates become our
friends every single one of these school
shootings have been from young men who
are disconnected and we talk a lot about
the mental health issues but it actually
goes deeper than that because there's a
lot of mentally ill children that are
kind and compassionate the focus really
needs to be on how can we connect I
think that was powerful for a lot of
people Greg brought that up we wanted to
play that sound bite for you and one
will get your reaction so I think today
was a wonderful day in terms of people
hearing voices earlier today you had the
students from Parkland who went to
Tallahassee to the State Capitol in
Florida they're arguing there that again
we need
and they're tired of the status quo and
it was an amazing turnout in fact I was
struck by the idea that these are people
who are 15 16 years old most of them
were not seniors in fact some of them
were high school freshmen but they spoke
with such passion
some of them choking back tears to try
to express not only their fears but you
know what they had lost and similarly I
think at the White House meeting the
ability to hear from young people really
strikes me as what's different it
changes the conversation because you can
say oh well these young people don't
have any really concrete ideas or better
ideas but I think that they are touching
something in the American spirit and
saying that we have to find a solution
so when you listen to what was being
said for example at the White House
meeting which I you know I think it
certainly has its publicity angle I
don't think that's where you really get
solutions I think what you hear there is
that this goes beyond schools that
people who are saying you know my kids
walking home from school or my kids
walking over to an AP program or my kids
waiting at the bus stop and they're just
so many guns around so how do we deal
with that how do you stop that that's
the challenge but as someone said we
have tons of ideas for solutions the
American people gun owners and non-gun
owners NRA and na na n RA agreed
basically on background checks on
limiting weapons that can become weapons
of mass destruction people agree on
arguments about gun safety and
preparedness and waiting periods these
are all very concrete ideas that are
there on the mental health side I think
that woman who stood up and said very
quickly
most people who have mental health
issues are not the ones who are shooting
up the police and that is really a Dodge
from the difficult issue of dealing with
the fact that we have a proliferation of
guns more guns than people in our
country it's crazy
Kimberly I'll give you a chance to
remark on anything you want thank you so
much you know it's interesting when I
listen today to the students expressing
themselves so passionate and eloquent
saying that they wanted to do something
about this that it was the passion
cause of their life that they weren't
going to forget it so that students can
go into school safe we owe that to the
children the students of America to make
sure that when they go through the
school doors in the morning and the bell
rings to go sit and pay attention in
class that they're able to pay attention
to the lesson and not worry about a
gunman coming through the door to kill
them and I want to take a moment to
honor the lives of those that were lost
and those that gave their lives trying
to save others and in particular yes
we've talked a lot about the the coach
who was incredible and all the people
that showed incredible valor in the face
of tremendous adversity and instead of
cowering in fear they ran towards to try
to save lives like the Junior ROTC
members that were absolutely of so
incredible Peter Wang 15 years of age
Elana patty 14 years of age and Martin
Duque also 14 imagine being that young
and having the presence of mind and
selflessness to say that I'm going to
stand in the way so that others may live
that I think is about training too from
the ROTC for absolutely and imagine if
all the students were equipped with that
kind of training and that we gave them
the means by which to protect themselves
and we actually made schools a place
where people said you know what I'm not
gonna go there to commit an act of
violence but it will not be allowed I
will not be able to permeate there and
go and do something and commit these
horrific acts because they are protected
yeah you know what the media did about
that they blamed the ROTC they did what
that that the killer was also trained oh
so they so they get instead of seeing
what Kimberly you know acutely pointed
out this Peter Wang it was at West Point
I guess has admitted him in the the
three the three Junior ROTC cadets or it
would maybe he says Peter Wang but three
had died well he wanted to go to West
Point yeah yeah yeah entrance into the
Academy we actually had the sound from
Andrew Pollock who is Jesse mentioned
daughter meadow died last week on
Wednesday just week ago today can we
play that my daughter has no voice she
was murdered last week and she was taken
from us
shot nine times on the third floor I'm
very angry that this happened because it
keeps happening 9/11 happened once and
they fixed everything how many schools
how many children have to get shot that
stops here with this administration and
me should have been one school shooting
and we should have fixed it
and I'm pissed because my daughter I'm
not gonna see again she's not here she's
not here I didn't think it was gonna
happen I mean if I knew it I would have
been at the school every day if I knew
it was that dangerous it's enough let's
get together work with the president and
fix the schools his passion is certainly
evident Jesse but also to have the
ability to come to the White House with
your sons and articulate yourself that
well and say that you're committed to
making sure it doesn't happen again it
was a very strong moment very strong he
really lit a fire under the president
that was the moment I think of the
entire event that people really began to
think this is never going to happen
again you can never listen to someone
talk like that that passionately and
then forget it a few weeks later said
something else pretty interesting to me
we protect everything we value in this
country with guns
we protect banks we protect politicians
we protect celebrities we protect
congressmen everything we value we
protect with guns why don't we ever
affect our children with guns and the
9/11 analogy is really critical
every school shooting is a mini 9/11 for
that school and for those families in
those communities and to have it happen
over and over and over again we've just
reached a critical mass in this country
and I think this is going to be the
moment what about that tipping point
Greg do you think culturally it is
something where you'll see maybe it'll
be difficult to get the legislation
through but it'll happen this year I
don't know I mean we live in a strange
time where the news is accelerated so
quickly that there are things I mean I'm
still like we don't know what happened
in vague like like this
this fiend was utterly preventable
obviously we saw how many mistakes but
we still don't know anything about the
Vegas thing and the [ __ ] doctor okay
yeah and the thing is I don't think
there was a possible way you could have
stopped Vegas because we don't even know
how long he planned when somebody
planned something it's gonna happen
three years if somebody is smart and has
a plan and we look I said this before
you know 9/11 was the second time right
it was the second attack on the World
Trade Center they went back and they
planned and does hurt if they tried it
once and then they came back and they
did it again
as long as there's evil in the world
there will be these incidents and we
can't expect them to disappear like that
however I will say this this is these
practical solutions are actually
practical I didn't heat I heard a motion
but I also heard rationality yeah it
wasn't simply people shouting do
something ban guns brand guns what you
heard were people that were actually
expressing practical rational solutions
to a problem and that is already in my
mind progress and we're actually talking
about it and I would I would suggest
that something like this I haven't seen
anything like this before but a town
hall like this pretending to other
issues like this where people are
intimately involved involving the
president is an interesting thing and
could be something that again I go back
to Donald Trump you know he's his
president sees a talk show maybe that's
not so bad because that's the talk show
you need let's see I don't agree because
I think you're gonna need to have some
kind of resolution with the right wing
talk show host and the NRA the people
who will say you're taking away my guns
like that goes back to the trust which I
think that is leading like this it's
terrific in terms of having a cathartic
moment I think for all of us as a
country to have to hear the pain and the
families to understand as we were saying
that this is like a 911 if since your
child is your family that man standing
up there saying he'll never see his
daughter again why didn't we fix this
that's powerful stuff but in terms of
actually resolving it I think you got to
get people together who will say let's
not kids gentlemen or ladies we're gonna
have to make a deal